It is the duty of every Muslim
that he should do da'a. Dava is
compulsory for every Muslim. What is the
meaning of the Arabic word dawa? The
Arabic word dava means to invite to call
and in Islamic context of Islam means
inviting the non-Muslims towards Islam.
I start my talk by quoting a verse of
the glorious Quran from surahel chapter
number 16 verse number 125 which says
invite all to the way of thy lord with
wisdom and preaching and argue with them
and reason with them in the ways that
are best most gracious. Here Allah is
saying to the Muslims, invite all to the
way of thy lord with wisdom and
beautiful preaching and argue with them
in the ways that are best, most
gracious. Allah says in the glorious
Quran in surah aliman chapter number
three verse number 110. Allah says,
"Oh ye Muslims, ye are the best of
peoples evolved for mankind." Allah is
giving us an honor. is calling us
Muslims as kra um the best of peoples
evolved for mankind. Allah is giving us
honor. Whenever there is honor, it is
always followers of a responsibility.
For example, in a school, a principal
has got more honor than a teacher. A
teacher has got more honor than a clerk.
Similarly
in a school the principal has got more
responsibility than a teacher. A teacher
had got more responsibility than a
clerk. There is no honor without
responsibility. So in this verse of the
Quran in surah Imran 310 Allah is
calling us Muslims as the best of
peoples. Don't you think we have a
responsibility? The reply is given in
the same verse. Allah continues and says
because we enjoy what is good and we
forbid what is wrong and we believe in
Allah. Allah is calling us the umah
because we Muslims are supposed to
enjoin what is good and forbid what is
wrong and believe in Allah. If we do not
enjoy what is good and if we do not
forbid what is wrong, we unfit to be
called asmah. We aren't fit to be called
as Muslims.
Doing d'a conveying the message of Islam
to non-Muslim is a and Allah says in
al-Ass
1 to3 it is known as the path to
salvation. Allah says
Allah is taking the oath of time and
he's saying by the token of time
man is wearily in a state of loss in
except those who have four criteras.
Except those who have faith, I iman,
those who have righteous deed, those who
exalt people to truth that is doing dawa
and Islah and those who invite pe those
who invite people to patience and
perseverance. So according to surah al
assur for any human being to go to Jenna
there are minimum four criterias
required im righteous deed
inviting people to truth that is dawa
and inviting people to patience and
pursuits. If anyone is missing under
normal circumstances you shall not go to
Jenna. You may be a very good Muslim.
You may be praying five times a day. You
may be having mark on the forehead. You
may be fasting in the month of Ramadan.
You may be giving zakat. You may have
gone for Hajj but if you do not do dawa
according to surah al assur under normal
circumstances you shall not go to Jenna.
If Allah wants to forgive you and put
you in Jenna that's Allah's prerogative
as Allah says in surah Nisa ch 4:48 and
nisa ch 416
if Allah pleases he may forgive any sin
but the sin of shik he'll not forgive.
So if Allah wants to forgive you and put
you in Jenna that's Allah's prerogative
but under normal circumstances if you
don't do dawa you shall not go to go to
Jenna only dawa is also not sufficient
all four are equally required im faith
righteous deed
inviting people doing dawa and
inviting people to patience and pursue
all four are equally important for you
to go to Jenna. So this was in short
telling you that dava is f for every
Muslim man or